el objetivo de este vídeo es encontrar
la anti derivada del logaritmo natural
de x y no es obvio cómo hacer esto
aunque yo te dijera que puedes usar
integración por partes tú podrías
preguntarte oye pero me este para
intentar integración por partes necesito
el producto de dos funciones y aquí solo
tengo una función logaritmo natural de x
sin embargo podemos hacer obvio esto si
escribimos esta integral como la
integral de logaritmo natural de x por 1
de x aquí tenemos el producto del
gobierno actual de xy la función 1 la
función constante 1 también la podemos
considerar como una función de x y ahora
ya es más obvio cómo usar integración
por partes integración por partes no se
establece que la integral de fx
que prima de x
de x esto es igual a y recordemos que la
regla integración por partes es el
inverso de la regla del producto esto es
f x por gd x
menos la integral si aquí tenemos f x
porque prima de x del otro lado de la
igualdad se invierten los papeles por lo
que se tiene menos la integral de f
prima de x por de x
v x
es una regla que ya hemos visto varias
veces y cuando se trata en contra de fx
ig prima de x para f x
queremos una función cuya derivada
facilite la evaluación de esta integral
y para ge prima de x la función que sea
fácil de anti derivar en este caso un
buen candidato para fx es logaritmo
natural de x su derivada es 1 / x
entonces hagamos
fx igual el logaritmo natural de x y f
prima de x es por tanto 1 / x y que
prima de x es igual a 1 g prima de x es
igual a 1 y la anti derivada de x es
igual a simplemente x apliquemos
entonces la fórmula el lado derecho de
esta integral va a ser fx porque de x f
x es igual a lo que natural de x no se
pone primero gxg de x es igual a x
por fx que es igual a logaritmo natural
de x me gusta poner x antes del gobierno
actual de x para evitar ambigüedad menos
la integral de f prima de x
efe prima de x que es 1 / x por gd x gx
es igual a x y esto hace es de x
simplifiquemos esté integrando aquí
tenemos 1 / x x x lo cual es simplemente
igual a 1 y esto simplifica bastante
bonito esto va a ser igual a vamos a
ponerlo por aquí esto es igual a esto
simplifica no aquí abajo esto es igual a
x
el logaritmo natural de x menos la anti
derivada de 1 de x o la anti derivada de
x en cuanto es la integral de 1d x la
anti derivada de de x es menos x y esta
es una anti derivada si quisiéramos la
anti derivada general le agregamos
simplemente más de la constante
integración y hemos terminado ya hemos
calculado la anti derivada del logaritmo
natural de x deriva esto para que
verifique en particular aquí va a tener
que aplicar la regla del producto
verifica que de hecho tienes logaritmo
natural de x cuando deriva sexto